good morning
it's Sunday and I love Sundays because
it's my little reset day that's the day
I really do try to SEC set myself up for
success for the upcoming week I really
do like getting my life in order when it
comes to a Sunday and I do like to do a
little bit more of a rigorous cleaning
so it's still in maintenance mode
however I do try to get a little bit
more specific so I do a room at a time
so this is the first room I've done
especially now that I have Mia she's a
husky German mix and Huskies I don't
know anything about German shepherds
they shed so much and that is so true
for Mia she sheds a ton bless you
bless you thank you thank you go blow
your nose please
perfect yep how I would have done it too
so I like to clean as often as I
possibly can so I did all the carpet I
did my little carrot oh shoot I forgot
to fold that I like vacuum vacuumed the
couches I picked up the cushions vacuum
underneath there I fluffed them so this
area technically is clean
oh
and it was
quite a bit oh and I cleaned Mia's room
would I like to call me his room so this
is Mia's room
I have a little like area where she
could lay down that's her carpet that's
her bed I cleaned her bed I did all of
that I cleaned the tracks I cleaned the
her door to her room
what are you barking at
cut it out Mia he doesn't want to play
yeah I cleaned her door I cleaned the
tracks I didn't sweep however I do
vacuum I just I
we get the house deep cleaned every two
every other week so two times a month it
gets full deep clean because we're not
the neatest people you know what I'm
saying mama
okay okay let's see
yeah so uh yeah sorry for ending that
abruptly
it's permanent marker
and I have done a good job I'm still
scrubbing it as we speak
um a lot of it has came out
this isn't the first time
we get a little bit of permanent marker
there's another like pink stain in my
bathtub
honestly it's not that big of a deal
it really isn't but I just wish I knew
what to use to get it off I think I'm
like I mean it it's pretty good you guys
saw how like deep of a purple that was
oh you can't even see it on camera
but it's there
you can't tell too much because there's
all this veining from the stone itself
it ain't a big deal but damn you have to
act quick with these bullfugs
or else it like really absorbs the color
and then it won't come out
okay what was I saying oh yeah so
you okay I think he wants to play just
tell her no
yeah don't even look at her
um
so I didn't sweep I don't sweep because
it just takes such a long time but I do
vacuum and just that area that I told
you
this is
all that Gunk it picked up that's just
one little area dude can you imagine
what the rest of my house is gonna look
like and this is literally just maybe
one week
of not cleaning I feel like I'm eating
this stuff I feel like it's like all
over me
so yeah I'm excited to do a slight deep
clean
what
what's funny
you don't want to play with this show
play by herself homia
that all that stuff down there is
me as brought over
look at all her toys
[Applause]
yep those are all her toys over there
it's like some hoof or a horn of some
sort
that's all Mia she came in through her
door
she's on her bed in her room
big cutie girl
and she doesn't help because she plays
out in that dirt and she brings most of
it back in
but she's so cute
oh she's she's out again
big dummy
just one cool feature of the house that
I just can't wait till spring rolls
around so that I can completely use it
today's actually a pretty good day it's
50 degrees out but it feels like a cool
low 60s look at this
I can open up
my back sliding door
the whole way and then taika is fighting
with Mia uh this side does the exact
same thing but because I have
she came back inside but because I have
her sliding door it's like an addition I
didn't want to permanently change our
door so I did have to add kind of like a
stop here
so I can't use it unless I remove the
door which if we ever do have like a
it's really different if we ever have a
gathering then for sure I'll move it but
for now I don't need to because look at
this
it's gorgeous look at that the whole
back is open
so can you imagine once you have our
pool done
[Music]
yeah he annoys me she annoys him so much
as if you can't tell but yeah can you
imagine how beautiful it's gonna look
once the pool's done this is like the
front door
this is your view hey how are you guys
and you're welcome holy crap that's
beautiful
okay so now I have moved into the office
and before we had any blinds
um
we had these windows that we couldn't
close because again we didn't have any
blinds or Shades or whatever you want to
call them
um but we would film our podcast or we
do film our podcast from here in the
daytime so
as you can see here the lighting is not
the best right so in the background
or the lighting behind you is really
bright you're not going to see the image
in front like it's going to look really
dark but here you see the difference so
that's optimal so because of that I got
like this like
film that you can place over the windows
that you can see here you see how it's
like Blurry so it's like this Frost film
that you could put on it I was able to
take it off without a sticky residue on
this side
but the sticky residue stayed like this
is all sticky
so to combat that I have this thing
called Gooby gone and it is so dope you
spray it on you wait a few minutes and
then it says supposedly you can
remove it
with a clean uh a clean air with soap
okay apply the gooby gone okay so blot
it
so okay so you can clean the area with
soap and water that's not true at least
for not this type of adhesive what I did
find was the same tool that I used to
apply that film which is this to take
out all the air bubbles I use it just to
scrape off the adhesive and you'll see
what I'm talking about so I'm going to
spray it on
and then I'm gonna wait like maybe five
minutes and then I'm gonna start
scraping it off and you'll see how easy
it comes off
okay so I'm standing on top of
Papa's desk don't tell him anyway
now I'm gonna start spraying the area
with this Gooby gongs
oh God and it gets all over the place
it really is like this oily
at least it smells good it smells like
oranges but it's
super oily and slimy
and you do want to saturate the area
for sure
because it's gonna make your life easy
it's kind of eating it up already huh
which is okay so I'm gonna let that
marinate for a bit
why are some like
super see-through and then some areas
are not
pretty crazy how like as soon as I
started spraying it like you'd see
through it okay so I'm gonna let it
marinate for a bit and then I'll start
the taking off process
okay check this out
look at this so that's all the adhesive
look
and now it just starts coming off pretty
gross
very satisfying at the same time
look at that
okay I gotta scrape this off but it
is amazing
okay so this is about 10 minutes worth
of work I did one initial pass and I
cleared out all the ones that just kind
of came off out of first swipe and then
with the residue I sprayed it again I
wait for another five minutes and then
this is kind of my halfway point of all
of that
look at all this the goo it's so gnarly
and nasty but this is after the second
pass
and then this is me kind of going back
and trying to clean it again let's see
if this looks better kind of but it is
body whereas this side
it's way more clear all those spots are
actually on the other side of the of the
glass but
it's a miracle worker so
if there's anything that you have that
has glue or gum or anything you're like
I Gotta Throw It Away no you don't
you just gotta get some of the
Gooby down
but yeah almost done
and we are done it came off like a
breeze definitely had to do a little bit
of work there but considering how sticky
it was it was actually pretty easy okay
let me put you on something else
so now you know about Gooby gone
a superior glass cleaner that you need
to have that's better than Windex it's
better than anything you've ever used
it's glass cleaner by straightway this
thing is literally streak free it's the
best I have ever used I like ton of
these bottles in my house it is the best
okay the cleaning continues let's keep
going but I'm just so stoked that's done
because it kept bugging me every time I
was in here yes clean so now we are at
McDonald's getting lunch and as the food
gets made I got taika somewhere in there
where are you
oh
okay well he's in there somewhere
this thing is pretty bad
oh there you are
okay go go back down go
see you later
so taika had his playdate at McDonald's
now it's Mia's turn hey you're gonna go
up the hill pay attention
dude you got to pay attention when you
drive okay you can't just press go go
that way where it's where it's flat
[Applause]
okay come on Mia
this guy's eating an apple pie while
driving the corner okay then pause don't
drive
don't drive
there's a lot going on all the time with
this guy like when I think we got it all
under control something happens like his
pie broke all of a sudden and now he
can't drive because it's gonna get all
over the place I don't even know how
that happens I don't even understand so
in the meantime he's gonna get some
little play time
tiger that part's gonna fall
okay hold on I gotta tend to this guy
because it's I don't even know how this
happened I'll be right back all right
potential crisis averted attack is back
we put the apple pie in the Box we're
good Mia's out exploring yeah
hi Mia you have a good time
you have a good time
go off and be a dog go be wild you're
free
can you no no no no no no
just drink and then move later
[Music]
every day I do that multiple times a day
just to
you know did you put the lid on it okay
it feels heavy yeah it's heavy no I'm
good thanks hold it please whoa this is
super heavy oh it's like a big old Nut
and Bolt
the conditions were too bumpy for taika
on this side
so this is the only way it's gonna work
what
oh very cool bamboo stick
yeah I was trying to make him go on that
way and somehow
I had to pull this thing over this hump
it doesn't seem steep by any means
God damn that was tiring
Mia come good girl
yep
that is
yeah well those are dry I don't think
you can feed it to them anymore
monkey what'd you say
um no that's not what you said you said
something about your car oh yeah
no you didn't say that either you said
my car looks so cool
yes you did you said my car looks so
cool are you embarrassed oh okay well
then he didn't say that
I totally said that
people you're gonna kill people with
spikes okay let's go kill her
all right let's go super villain
yeah drink some
you're thirsty
good girl Mia thank you for waiting this
was supposed to be for you but somehow
we made it about taika again
hurry up you little super villain
I guess you'd like to be called right
you don't want to be the hero you want
to be the villain
good job
I'd be pretty bad
no you're all right okay you're spilling
your Gatorade everywhere okay another
crisis one second
Tech I get so annoyed by Mia and all she
wants to do is just play with him
look at her
she asks for it
huh
he looks like a cartoon
character look at her
she wants all the smoke
I'm just trying to get all that smoke
she's gonna get it oh that is in
the pool
he just threw dirt on himself
she's right in front of him like what
what are you gonna do now
what are you gonna do now huh
I told him to come inside to take a nap
like 10 minutes ago honestly he got
distracted
let's come in take a nap
we really do feel like naps and just
getting a sufficient amount of sleep
which is about 10 hours for this guy
um has helped him not get a seizure so
if I were going into three months no
seizures was prior to this it was a
seizure every month so good track record
over there
right there
yep now I'm tackling my bedroom
clean clothes folded stacked on top of
my luggage
that it took with me to Austin
hangers that we have extra that I need
to find a place to put it this is on top
of a box because I don't want it
touching the floor even though I
vacuumed before I put anything on the
floor washing my bed
there's a lot going on you guys
trying to organize all the that
I have that I'm like okay at this point
I'm just hoarding so I'm
fortunate enough to where I get
PR packages from companies that want to
send me stuff they want me to try it out
or you know potentially promote it to
you guys or pass it on to you guys if I
like the product
and I've stopped doing that now for a
year I don't want to take on any more PR
packages because maybe even two years
now at this point because I think it's
just a waste I think it's a waste of
like I am grateful and I appreciate it
but they send you so much like if they
come out with a new Foundation you get
the whole thing of foundation and I'm
like okay I only have like two friends
like who am I gonna give these other 24
Shades up and it just feels very very
very uh uh wasteful so if anything I'll
just buy the product and if I like the
product I'll share it with you other
than that I refuse to take anything else
on just because I ain't a beauty Guru I
ain't that type I'm not using it on a
daily basis I hello
you know what I'm saying so because of
that I still have like an abundance of
things that I've had for the past couple
of years now because no surprise
I can't get to it because it's just so
much and I know I sound like I'm
complaining but I'm definitely not
um I just want to like be like
I have way too much and it's dope that I
have family members and friends that are
always so down to take it
um so that's what I'm doing I'm putting
it in piles of like
hair face Sun stuff makeup uh dude wanna
know what one of my hobbies was uh when
the pandemic first struck and we were on
lockdown who else got into
gel X nails and doing their own Nails
because everything was obviously closed
yep I have the whole set baby I have
everything you can think of I even got
this thing and I was so happy because
it's just so cute but yeah
I don't do that anymore but if we
want to have a gel X party I'm
bringing all this because
look at how many extensions I got
[Applause]
yeah
um I have way too many
so
I'm gonna do if you want to do your
nails hit me up I'm Pro with
this but yeah this is where we're
at and at the same time I'm trying to
watch taika
because I told his ass not to go into
the pool anymore
don't go in the pool
I already told you get out
so yeah the excavation has happened and
now
the pool they've kind of like put the
steps in where all that stuff is at he
looks so cool him and his dog what
huh
let me see how do I open this
watch out
this is so cool
hey um didn't I tell you not to go in
that pool no because I did ahead of you
yes I left the door open and I told you
don't climb on the thing remember and
you were using the sticks to get out
yeah I told you don't climb in there
because it's really loose the the dirt
is really loose there and you could get
really hurt
did you hear me now what did I say
dude don't go in the pool
what did I say
okay see you later go play
hi Mia
don't come in here
no no no she said get out
get out
just ate her poop
did you eat your poop yeah disgusting
get out of here
oh no
her pause
are full of dirt get out of here
yeah
where is she Mia
Mia
are you sure where
[Applause]
hey Mia
hey
okay no no no get out get out
oh
don't see that word
outside
come on come on go outside go outside
go outside go go outside
go outside good girl smart girl come on
come on Mia no do not force it closed do
not close it I'll close it
hey
oh my God this is cool to what yeah
well that's a lot of big diarrhea that's
a lot of diarrhea poop I'm happy she
does it in one spot now remember when
she used to do it outside of our door
she's I think she's gonna come back in
yeah oh no she used to poop right there
it was a worse and I trained her so now
I'm really happy
she poops over here
what is she doing
what are you doing
are you eating
that's so cute there is no better
feeling
than clean sheets
this is my favorite I'm still washing my
if you don't know Bart and I have
different body temperatures and we
prefer to sleep with very different
temperatures so I'm a very cold person
so I have to sleep with two covers he's
a very hot person so I used to sleep
with one right now since we're in the
thick of winter
um he uses this that's a little bit
thicker he swears that it just it's so
hot
so I'm watching that too now more than
ever because we have me and she loves
shrimping on the bed I have to wash it
everything like every single week like
cannot go over a week because then just
the hair grosses me out
but we got the young Tykes taking a
shower
and look who decided to join the party
the man himself who just drove
four hours but has had such a busy three
days shooting long days of JK news
damn you're cooking you want me to do it
no it's okay my days are long because I
start at nine no if we shoot at night
now I start my days at five so I can
trade damn so I'm tired but looking
pretty good
have you seen my DMs
but you're still texting me
sending me all like songs and I
love you so much all right okay so
the guy is back
makes me really happy
um but because I've been on like a
cleaning frenzy just because all the dog
hair
I just didn't have time to go to the
grocery store so I'm so happy that I
live in an era
would they bring the groceries to you so
MIA is ready for her day
I'm gonna start my cut tomorrow actually
what happened
oh
I start my cut tomorrow so I started
buying all of my cut Foods so I saw this
rice I don't know how good it is but
right rice I hope it's not bad
it has two fat and 10 grams of protein
boy
and then I got my little monkey some
fruits he loves strawberries I shouldn't
even say fruits because it's not fruits
he just likes strawberries and I've
washed them yet washed what any of the
fruits no not yet why you want some I'm
kind of thirsty do you want water no
food
okay which ones do you want okay I got
you I got this I got him his excuse me
Mia she's like waiting for any little
thing to drop
um I got some spinach some roast frozen
veggies I got some cucumbers I make this
with uh the seasoning excuse me
excuse me uh excuse me uh
um I got some portobello mushrooms never
made these before but it looks promising
especially so I like the mushroom flavor
when it comes to lean meats that I have
to eat when I'm cutting because it just
makes my meat taste a little bit beefier
if that makes sense
without the fat
um and then I got some asparagus
oh and Tiger's Milk did I say that yeah
ready to rock got the fair life for the
high protein what else didn't get any
junk food
but I had my fair share like today I had
McDonald's this is taika's half eaten
apple pie even taika he's gonna start
eating healthier like anytime we go on a
cut the whole family goes on a cut
together
[Applause]
for the most part
but uh Papa's been doing it now for how
long a month
I don't know two months about a month
and a half now what was so funny I don't
know what was so funny about that I
think you always think I'm only
I'm always tired but
I mean it looks like it's been a month
maybe even two weeks so I think he's
been cutting for like two weeks he's
still flexing
um yeah I don't know what was so funny
anyway look at this little tomato paste
I didn't know it was gonna come this
small I also didn't know this was gonna
come this small but I mean whatever
it'll last her for the week so we should
be good
my little cute girl I love her so much
yeah and on that note I'm gonna go check
on taika make sure he's all right it
always scares me a bit to have him take
a shower on his own especially because
he's epileptic epileptic so I never want
to risk it so I'm gonna go see
he's good he's probably getting into
trouble
what nothing what are you doing
okay
say good night
am I gonna put the camera on you just
say goodnight everybody
[Music]
okay doesn't want to all right well
anyway on that note I got a lot of
to do good night everybody
see you tomorrow bye-bye